Welcome to Biographics.
Today’s highly recognizably protagonist
was hailed as genius of entertainment, a wizard
of animation, a pioneer of technology and
theme parks.
The influence of Walt Disney on today’s
popular culture and collective imagination
cannot be understated.
You can love him, hate him, or love to hate
him, but you cannot ignore his work.
Walt Disney once famously said that that laughter
is America’s greatest export.
It’s not.
It’s travel and transportation, with $236
Billion in sales in 2017.
But sale of intellectual property, including
TV and movies, amount to $49 Billion, which
is twice the GDP of Cyprus.
So, if by laughter we mean entertainment,
then yes – American entertainment is one
of the country’s most important exports,
and these days, a good chunk of that intellectual
property is owned by Walt Disney Studios:
Pixar, Buenavista, and Miramax, plus the Marvel
and the Star Wars franchises, are some of
the largest and most visible entertainment
companies owned by the House of Mouse.
Disney’s legacy can capture the imagination
of every girl or boy from early childhood
all the way through adulthood.
And to think -- it all started with the doodle
of a mouse, sketched during a depressing train
ride home.
But we’re getting ahead of ourselves...
Toilet Paper and Start Ups
Walter Elias Disney, later known as Uncle
Walt, was born on December 5, 1901, in Chicago,
Illinois.
His parents, Flora and Elias, were farmers
and occasional entrepreneurs of Canadian origin.
Walt was the youngest of five siblings, the
others being Ruth, Roy, Raymond and Herbert.
His much older brothers would prove a source
of stability and inspiration later in life.
At the age of seven, Walt and the Disneys
moved to Kansas City, where he spent most
of his childhood.
This was an unhappy period of his life.
Elias Sr had a hard time making a living,
switching from farming to distributing newspapers.
In each of these activities, Walt and his
siblings were drafted to work hard and contribute
to the family’s welfare.
Elias was a tough taskmaster and did not approve
of Walt trying to carve out time to do homework
or even attend school.
You can probably imagine how Elias took to
his son’s budding talent for drawing – he
considered it a complete waste of time and
would not spend a cent on something as futile
as art supplies.
Walt was reduced to drawing his first sketches
on toilet paper.
Walt’s harsh relationship with his father
was mitigated by Walt’s close relationship
with his big brothers, especially Roy and
Herbert, who were an early source of encouragement.
Unfortunately, Roy, Raymond and Herbert moved
out of the family home eventually, leaving
behind the much younger Walt.
In 1917, the US joined the Entente in WWI.
Alongside many other patriotic American boys,
Walt longed to do his part by donning a uniform
to serve in France.
He may have also had the added motivation
to leave his home behind.
Considering the fact that he faked his age
to join the army at 16, Walt was likely trying
to escape from his home life.
Unfortunately, he was rejected for being too
short.
Walt had a Plan B: he successfully applied
to join the American Red Cross.
While training as an ambulance driver, Walt
developed his artistic skills, and he became
quite popular for decorating the ambulances
with cartoons and caricatures of fellow paramedics.
One of his fellow trainees was one Ray Kroc
– the legendary CEO of McDonald’s.
Walt’s appetite for action remained unfulfilled;
the war was over before he was even deployed
overseas.
But when he returned home, he had a good reason
to rejoice -- he found out he had won a scholarship
to attend the Kansas City Art Institute.
After years of having to draw on toilet paper
and ambulances, the poor guy deserved a break.
And proper art supplies!
While attending the Art Institute, Walt developed
a fascination for the growing genre of animation.
Animated shorts were commonly used at the
time in movie theatres as a crowd pleaser
before the main feature.
But they were crudely made, the soundtrack
was irrelevant and some of them were just
creepy as hell.
Walt saw an opportunity to fill a potential
gap in the market with products of good quality.
With a friend from the Art Institute, Ub Iwerks,
Walt set up his first animation company.
It was a bold move, considering that the two
were nineteen and had little to no capital
to start with.
Walt and Ub developed a series of short animated
movies for the Newman chain of cinemas entitled
"Newman's Laugh-O-Grams".
The company was short lived, running from
1920 to 1923, but its cartoons were a hit
with audiences.
Walt experimented with some of the themes
that would become a staple of his later production:
anthropomorphised animals, innovative takes
on classic fairy tales, a keen ear for popular
music – jazz at that time - and slapstick
humour.
Though Walt and Ub were talented animators,
as businessmen, they were, well … they were
pretty rubbish.
The production costs of their shorts were
too high, and they signed unfair distribution
deals.
They thought they had hit jackpot when a distributor
company called Pictorial Clubs of Tennessee
promised $11,100 for six cartoons - $142,000
in today’s money.
But Pictorial never paid, and the Laugh-o-gram
company soon went bankrupt.
Interest asiding here: if today, some Laugh-o-grams
are still in tact and available, it’s thanks
to those Pictorial Clubs scoundrels – they
kept the six cartoons in their vault and reissued
them when Disney had become a household name.
The fellow animator, and other employees of
Walt’s start-up, were about to call it quits.
But Walt had a brilliant idea, with great
potential: how about mixing live action with
animation?
Walt’s pitch was to film a series of shorts
starring child actress Virginia Davis with
an innovative technique: mixing a live action
protagonist with animated characters and settings.
Walt and Ub moved to California to start work
on this new series, entitled the "Alice Comedies".
Their early work attracted the attention of
a New York based distributor, Margaret J.
Winkler.
Disney’s work was again plagued by high
production costs, which made the first Alice
Comedies unprofitable.
On Winkler’s insistence, Walt and Ub were
forced to increase their rate of production,
while lowering the animators’ salaries.
By this time big brother Roy Disney had joined
the company and he seemed to have a much better
business sense than Walt.
He would remain his business partner and trusted
advisor for the rest of his life.
It was perhaps on Roy’s advice that Walt
and Ub decided to hire an entirely female
crew of colourists.
Traditional animation requires for each frame
of a cartoon to be coloured by hand.
That’s 24 frames per second of footage.
So, it’s a meticulous, repetitive, time
consuming job requiring large numbers of skilled
professionals.
At that time, women’s wages were much lower
than men, which meant big savings for the
Disney brothers.
One of the colourists was a young woman from
Idaho called Lillian.
At the end of a long day’s work, Walt would
routinely drive home a group of his employees.
Whatever the route, he would always make sure
that the last person to be dropped off was
Lillian, so that he could spend more time
alone with her.
Lillian probably got the hint, and the two
started dating.
This led to a short engagement, and, eventually,
their wedding, in July of 1925.
By 1927, American audiences had grown weary
of the Alice Comedies shorts, and Walt wanted
to diversify his production.
He started working on a new character, Oswald
the Lucky Rabbit.
This series was successful, and Walt considered
rescinding his contract with Margaret Winkler
to chance distribution on his own.
But in 1928, Walt discovered that Margaret
and her husband, Charles Mintz, later of Universal
Pictures, were masters of the fine print at
the bottom of contracts.
During a business meeting in New York, he
learned that, as part of his deal with Winkler,
every intellectual property developed within
the terms of the contract would be legally
owned by Winkler and Mintz.
Unbeknownst to him, the New York power couple
had another nasty trick in reserve.
Their pushy demands and deadlines for the
Alice films alienated Disney’s animators.
Most of them had vented their frustration
against Walt – rather than Winkler.
So, when they eventually quit the company,
they were hired en masse by Universal!
Only Iwerks would remain by Walt’s side.
While riding the train back to California
from New York, a depressed Walt Disney put
pencil to paper to soothe his sadness and
frustration.
Little did he know, that doodle would change
his life, and have a huge impact on the lives
of millions of children.
The character he sketched that day was the
immortal Mortimer Mouse.
House of Mouse
‘Mortimer who?’ you may ask.
Well, that character was Mickey Mouse, but
Walt’s initial choice of name was Mortimer.
Luckily Lillian talked him to his senses and
advised he change the name to Mickey.
If you are into this sort of thing, the name
“Mortimer” is of old French origin and
means ‘Dead Sea’ – not the cheeriest
of names for a talking mouse!
Walt’s company was now called Walt Disney
Cartoons.
A skeleton crew which included only him and
Ub on drawing and animation duties, with Roy
supervising the business, and his wife and
Edna colouring and inking with Lillian.
The gang soon delivered three Mickey Mouse
cartoons.
The first two did not sell.
For the third one, Walt had the intuition
to add a recent cinematic innovation: a synchronized
soundtrack, which included a catchy whistling
tune.
This third cartoon was ‘Steamboat Willie.’
It opened on November 18, 1928 and it was
an immediate success for Walt Disney Cartoons.
Finally the big break had arrived and the
company would produce a string of hit animated
shorts.
In 1929, they created the cartoon series 'Silly
Symphonies'.
A 1932 episode, Flowers and Trees, was the
first cartoon to be produced in colour and
to win an Oscar.
The follow up, the Three Little Pigs of 1933,
was so popular that it got top billing above
the feature films it accompanied.
While working on the Silly Symphonies, Walt
and Lillian were trying to conceive a child.
Unfortunately Lillian suffered several miscarriages
which caused Walt to experience a nervous
breakdown.
Eventually, a baby girl named Diane arrived
in 1933.
The Disneys decided to adopt another girl,
Sharon, in 1936.
The successes of his cartoons and a growing
family emboldened Walt, who now started to
think big: why should cartoons be developed
only in short format?
Why not produce a full-length feature animated
film?
Your wish will soon come true
In 1934, Walt started working on that idea:
a cartoon that ran the length of a feature
film.
As he had done previously, Walt sought inspiration
from a classic Fairy Tale: Snow White by the
Brothers Grimm.
Nobody in Hollywood believed in Walt.
Among the studio lots, film executives sneered
at the project, calling it "Disney's Folly".
The production was not easy, going over time
and over budget.
But when Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs opened
on the December 21, 1937 it won immediately
the hearts and minds of both audiences and
critics.
Including subsequent releases, and adjusting
for inflation, Snow White is the tenth highest
grossing movie of all times.
At the 1938 Academy Awards, the film was nominated
for best soundtrack and received a Special
Award for ‘significant screen innovation’
– in the shape of one normal-sized Oscar
and seven little statuettes.
Walt Disney Studios continued working on shorts,
but the main production focus was firmly on
feature-length cartoons.
Walt’s next two projects were incredibly
ambitious: he released Pinocchio and Fantasia,
both in 1940.
Pinocchio was a relative success – not as
astounding as Snow White - but Fantasia tanked.
If you haven’t seen it yet, press pause,
go and find a DVD, a VHS, a Betamax, whatever,
and watch it now.
Welcome back.
Seen it?
Did you like it?
I told you it was awesome!
But 1940 audiences did not agree with our
modern sensibilities, and for the next production,
Dumbo, Walt had to tighten the belt and reduce
costs to a minimum.
Dumbo’s artwork and animation are visibly
cruder than the three previous movies, and
the runtime is also quite short – but the
film was highly profitable.
This relative reduction in quality may have
also been a consequence of a studio animators’
strike, an event which deeply angered and
worried Disney.
Boss Disney
A 2006 biography of Walt Disney by Neal Gabler
sheds some light on Walt’s relationship
with his employees, trade unions, and communism.
To put it simply, Walt Disney was a tough
boss to work for: it is no surprise that his
employees wanted to organise themselves in
a union, but he considered industrial action
as a dangerous expression of communist tendencies.
Think of this example.
When Walt turned 35, his brother Roy encouraged
employees to throw the boss a surprise birthday
party.
Two of the animators thought it would be a
fun idea to create a short cartoon of Mickey
and Minnie Mouse … going at it.
(Wink wink, nudge nudge.)
When Walt saw the animation at the party,
he laughed hard and asked who had made the
film.
The two animators stepped up, expecting a
pat on the back or a handshake.
He fired them on the spot.
In general, Walt could be controlling and
asked a lot from his employees, resorting
to humiliating dress-downs if they did not
deliver.
Even Roy was not spared.
The business brain behind Walt Disney studios
was frequently scolded when he offered an
opinion on artistic choices.
Uncle Walt’s employees, animators, and cartoonists
were the ones subject to longest hours and
gruelling work conditions.
Taking a break was a luxury, as Walt would
often appear suddenly in the drawing rooms
to check on their work.
Luckily for the employees, Walt was a heavy
smoker: with time he had developed a persistent
cough that announced his arrival by a few
seconds!
When his cartoonists tried to form a union,
Walt reacted by hiring armed guards, firing
organisers and cutting wages.
Well, the 1941 strike … but he really asked
for it!
On the July 2, 1941 Disney published an advert
in Variety, accusing the strike leaders of
‘Communistic agitation’.
This concern about Communist infiltrations
in Hollywood led him to join the Motion Picture
Alliance for the Preservation of American
Ideals, or MPA.
Founded in February 1944, the MPA was an organisation
composed of high-profile showbiz personalities
with the purpose of defending Hollywood – and
America as a whole – against Communism and
Fascism.
The MPA was active until 1975 and notable
members included John Wayne, Ronald Reagan
and Ginger Rogers to name a few.
The MPA volunteered to testify in front of
the House Committee on Un-American Activities.
The Committee was created in 1938 to investigate
alleged disloyalty and subversive activities
on the part of private citizens, public employees,
and organizations suspected of having Communist
ties.
Walt also participated in the hearings of
the committee, accusing several leaders of
the animators’ strike of being Communist
agitators.
His testimony earned him the gratitude and
friendship of legendary FBI Director J. Edgar
Hoover – one whose life we’ll tell sooner
or later.
Hoover and Disney developed a strange artistic
partnership.
In the following years, J. Edgar allowed Walt
Disney Studios to film some of their live
action movies at the FBI headquarters in Washington.
Walt, on the other hand, agreed to submit
some of his scripts to Hoover for an early
revision, to ensure that the FBI was depicted
correctly, but apparently, Hoover did not
make any changes to the classic animated films.
This is an odd refrain he would have slashed
half of Peter Pan’s script for depicting
an anarchist commune and abuse of substances
that literally get you flying.
In addition to these exchanges of favours,
Hoover had Disney appointed as ‘Special
Agent in Charge Contact’ in 1954.
In other words: a trusted informer and collaborator
of the FBI.
Fun fact – decades after Walt Disney’s
death, his company would pay homage to the
FBI chief with a minor character: J. Gander
Hooter from TV series Darkwing Duck.
In the 1950s Walt Disney eventually distanced
himself from the MPA, as he lost interest
in their ideals and their paranoid approach
to anti-Communism.
Walt’s association with the MPA is the source
of the rumour that he was anti-Semitic, but
biographer Neal Gabler, otherwise a harsh
critic of Disney’s, dismisses this claim
as unsubstantiated.
Walt regularly hired, or had business with,
Jewish employees and colleagues.
In 1955 he was even appointed ‘man of the
year’ by the B’nai B’rith International,
a Jewish cultural organisation.
This is not the only persistent, unfounded
rumour on Walt, more on this later.
A Triumph of the Imagination
In the 1950s and 1960s Walt Disney studios
produced a series of animated masterpieces
that won well-deserved popular success.
I’ll list them all, because I know if I
miss one, I’ll get backlash in the comments:
Cinderella (1950), Alice in Wonderland (1951),
Peter Pan (1953), Lady and the Tramp (1955),
Sleeping Beauty (1959), 101 Dalmatians (1961)
and Mary Poppins (1964).
Everybody has a favourite of course, but what
about your least favourite?
Write your vote in the comments and tell us
why you chose it!
My personal favourite?
Why! ‘tis Mary Poppins of course!
Not only Dick Van Dyke’s spot on cockney
accent reminds me of my relatives in London
… but it’s Disney’s first superhero
movie if you think about it – long before
the Marvel acquisition came along.
Mary has the powers of
Flight
Telekinesis
Interdimensional travel
Mind manipulation through the medium of song
Infinite storage capabilities
So, yeah, studio executives, when you are
planning the next Avengers film, how about
you draft in Poppins, too?
Mary Poppins successfully merged live action
and animation in colour.
Before that, Disney studios had ventured into
purely live action films, the first one being
Treasure Island in 1950.
Disney was also one of the first Hollywood
producers to invest in TV.
The first of his series on the small screen
was The Magical World of Disney – which
actually can be considered an early example
of Content Marketing to promote a good or
service.
What was Disney promoting?
His next big dream, the one that would take
most of his energy and attention for the last
decade of his life, was a massive, innovative
theme park in Southern California: Disneyland.
The park was developed in the town of Anaheim,
after demographics experts convinced Walt
that it would become a major population centre
within 10 years.
Tme would prove they were right, when local
population, and park visitors, soared.
Disneyland opened on the July 17, 1955 and
its first day was a disaster.
30,000 people turned up instead of the projected
15,000, meaning restaurants were soon out
of food and drink.
A plumber’s strike forced Walt to choose:
either have flushing toilets or working drinking
fountains.
He chose the toilets.
One of the attractions was so overgrown with
weeds that Disney ordered to place around
placards with Latin names.
To disguise the shrubbery as an arboretum,
in other words!
Of course, everything improved, and Disneyland
became one of the most, if not the most visited
and successful theme parks Worldwide.
When looking at visitors’ stats, Disney
realised that only a small fraction came from
the West Coast.
That’s when he got the idea of building
a sister park in Florida, Disney World, developed
around the prototype of a futuristic perfect
city, called EPCOT.
But Walt Disney would not live to see his
new dream come true.
For most of his adult life he had been smoking
three packs of unfiltered cigarettes, every
day.
His daughter Diane tried, and failed, to convince
him to cut back.
They reached a compromise: he would at least
smoke three packs of filtered cigarettes – but
he just removed the filters behind Diane’s
back!
Inevitably in 1966, Walt Disney was diagnosed
with lung cancer.
He underwent surgery, but due to post-operative
complications, Walt had a heart attack and
died on December 15, 1966 at age 65.
Contrary to popular and persistent rumours,
his body was NOT cryogenically preserved and/or
hidden in a vault under Disneyland.
Walt was simply cremated, and his ashes were
interred at Forest Lawn Cemetery in Los Angeles,
California.
Legacy
I hope you forgive me for stating the obvious,
but Walt Disney was, and still is, a controversial
figure, as is normal for somebody whose influence
on the surrounding world and society is larger
than life.
A personality like Disney will never be free
from exaggerations, slander and rumours – or,
the opposite risk, is to portray him exclusively
in a saintly light.
For sure, Walt Disney was certainly not the
fairest of business leaders, not the most
balanced of workplace bosses, not the most
level-headed when confronted with different
political ideas.
But it is also true that he did deliver a
lasting impact on society, culture and children
through his innovative work.
As Walt once said:
“I'd rather entertain and hope that people
learn, than teach and hope that people are
entertained”